Amandla cleats is scared of her new
normal after having an intimate memorial
in memory of her late husband Nick
Cordero Amanda gets real about life
without her partner if Nick died on July
5th after 95 days in the ICU battling
complications from coronavirus in that
time the performer had his leg amputated
lost 65 pounds and was put in a coma the
Broadway stars wife took to Instagram on
Sunday to share details of the emotional
event in the heartfelt Post Amanda said
Nick would have wanted his memorial to
be a celebration she told the few guests
in attendance to try to laugh share
great stories and sing for him into his
memory Amanda said Nick would have loved
the memorial it was beautiful and
perfect his spirit was definitely there
the fitness instructor shared that the
group listened to the song I'm here from
the Broadway show the color purple
Amanda reflected on a beautiful memory
she had with her husband writing Nick
and I saw the show on Broadway years ago
and we left the theater in tears
speechless as it was being played last
night the lyrics in the second half of
the song hit me hard
truly I am scared scared of my new
normal of the pain the loss and being
strong enough to get through it but she
knows that Nick believes in her and
wants her to live this new life quote he
wants me to be the best version of
myself for our son Amanda said she
promised Nick in the hospital that she
would try to do that and I'm it's when
in doubt she will listen to the song for
strength
whoa it will be my motto Amanda
continued by telling her followers she
never thought this would be her journey
and that she's going to take one day one
step at a time she shared I have faith
that God is leading the way and that
Nick is our angel the fitness trainer
concluded her post by sharing the lyrics
too I'm here and encouraging fans to
listen to Cynthia revos rendition of the
song
Cynthia commented on the post saying in
part I am honored to be a vessel for a
song that is larger than I can
ever be here for you with music whenever
you and I'll veto need it it's tough for
sure Amanda has been incredibly open
about her grief after Nick's death it
oftentimes doesn't hit me until date but
I'm going to sleep I don't know if
there's a right answer I don't think
there is a right answer to grief or or
how some what grieves or the process you
go
last week she tearfully told fans that
she finds herself still talking to her
late husband I said to Nick I was like
you Dobie this is what I would be doing
I would keep going I would keep moving I
would keep working I thought maybe that
would make him laugh you know because
that I think he's listening but save
time it's you know it's it's so hard
um and what it does here you it's so
hard but I know that it's good easier
every day
you
you